everyone knows that 0 *
anything equals 0, but why?
your intuition is probably telling you
that multiplication is repeated addition
and if I add zero copies of something
then of course I have zero things
if you have a bit of math knowledge
you might go beyond intuition and say
"that's just how multiplication is defined:
0 is the base case, 0 * anything equals 0,
and multiplication of larger numbers is
defined by saying (y + 1) * x = y * x + x"
but we use the symbol "0" for a lot
more than just the natural numbers
0 the natural number * anything equals 0
0 the real number times anything equals 0
0 in modular arithmetic times anything equals 0
the 0 matrix * anything equals 0
the constant zero function times anything equals 0
and even the zero function
convolution anything equals zero
these are all different types of zeros
and different types of multiplication
they're definitely not simple repeated addition
and yet we still end up with
0 * anything equals 0, why?
let's prove it and see what about
zero actually makes this happen
start with the expression 0 * x
for now you can assume these are real numbers
but we'll see shortly that's not necessary
0 is 0+ 0 because 0 plus anything is that thing
then because addition distributes
this is 0 * x plus 0 * x
at this point in the proof we don't know that 0
* x equals 0 but we know that it's some number
and we know that number has a negative
so let's add that negative
to both sides of the equation
then group with parens
and since a number plus its negative
is zero we get 0 = 0 + 0 * x
and since again 0 plus anything is that thing
we finally arrive at 0 * x = 0
in this proof the only facts we really used
are: that 0 plus anything equals that thing,
that addition distributes over multiplication,
that every number has a negative
that cancels it to give zero,
and if you want to be real technical we
did also use associativity to group parens
we don't even need commutativity
of addition or multiplication
which is good because matrix
multiplication is not commutative
if you're applying for grad
school you might describe this as
"the identity for an associative
invertible operation is absorbing
for any other operation that
distributes over the first"
that's why it works for matrices,
functions, convolutions, and many more
because all these types of
objects satisfy common axioms
which in particular include the properties we need
and no this does not prove
that 0 * Infinity equals 0
the proof only works if 0 * Infinity is
defined so that we can do algebra on it
but 0 * Infinity isn't defined so no proof
although if you're a teacher it's a fun exercise
to ask your students to explain why
the proof breaks down for Infinity
anyway you're probably wondering
"well what about those assumptions?"
is there a similar trick to show that
0 plus anything equals that thing?
it feels like a very similar kind of problem
usually this is just shown manually
because the behavior of zero under
addition is closely aligned to
the definition of addition itself
a lot of the time you give the label
zero to an element of your number system
precisely because it has the property
that it does nothing under your addition
so maybe the real question is "how do
we normally define addition at all?"
great question, maybe a topic for another video
thanks for watching, as always thank you to my
viewers who support the channel through
patreon and other forms of donation
slap that like button an odd number of
times and I'll see you in the next one